Okay. Hey, what's going on it's Bill
Burr. It's time for the mon-. Uh,
no it is noo It's the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast
and Oh,
I'm just checking in on your,
sorry, I'm saving my voice.
I fucked up my voice a couple of months
ago and I've just ignored it and now I
am. I'm throat coding teeing it. Um, mmm.
I got some halls sucking
on the halls there.
Dude. It's still fucking metal lip. This
well never fucking says on the thing.
Hauls mental lipless mental lip.
This eucalyptus. I don't
know. Take a steam. You,
what you need to do for your
voice is you need to stop talking.
You need to drink some condensed milk.
It's like 20 people right now.
What could those middle global actually
closed phlegm. Shut the fuck up.
You never went to medical school. Okay.
All you did was drink a glass of milk.
Stop talking like you're a fucking
veterinarian. Ah, you know,
I didn't want to be in a mood like
this. Um, all right, so Billy,
no fun.
Now I've cried wolf for
about three weeks right now.
Talking about how I was going to get my
act together, right. And I was gonna,
I was gonna start working clean
on stage. I was going to, uh,
you know, get my relationship
with Christ going again,
ma'am. Talk to that guy and fucking
fucking forever. We had a big falling out,
me and that guy, you know, and I still
feel like he owes me the apology.
I'm waiting for him to call, you
know, waiting for him to reach out.
But, uh, you know, I could see that he's
being a big baby about it. So evidently,
you know, I'm gonna have to
be the bigger man, you know,
I'm going to have to reach
out. Jesus. If you could,
could you help me avoid
the demon of the booze? Um,
no, I was good at this. This is how,
this is how much I've been eating
and drinking like a fucking asshole.
I just shut everything down Sunday
night and I lost four pounds this week,
you know, just fucking, and I
even got hammered one night.
I was doing so well,
dude, the 4th of July.
Happy Birthday,
dare United States of America.
Happy Birthday dear
United States of America.
Happy Birthday.
Still Fenders of free,
the
MMM.
You live in on goop and we want it pay.
Oh Jesus. Anyways, on July 4th,
you know how many Burgers
I had? Zero. How many hot dogs?
I had zero up.
You know how much alcohol I had.
Zero until a couple came over.
I'm French. You know, they
brought their kids over, you
know, they had a little one,
then they had one that was like seven,
eight years old.
It was a riot telling me knock knock
jokes. He was killing me, killing me.
It's delivery was outstanding. He was
making up his own knock knock jokes,
but just the way he would do the,
deliver the punchline, he'd be like, um,
um, okay. I got one, I got
one. He was just making them
up on the spot. He'd be like,
knock, knock. I'd be like,
who's there? And He'd be like,
Liz [inaudible] Liz who when he'd be like,
listen to my music.
Yeah, give me, you come up with one on
the spot. Those aren't easy. Um, anyways,
so we ended up having, I
had a great time, but uh,
you know the guy brought over some
beers, so I'm like, ed, he's not cold.
I got a couple of cores up.
The is liking on the little grenade
fucking bottles in the back. I'm like,
I'll have one. So I have one. There
were only here for an hour. Right.
But what did I do?
I sprinkled a little fairy dust on it,
demon in me and then the demon will
governments like walk over to your bar,
record ship to Korea. And I did, you know,
big fucking square ice cube, nice home
poor and the bottle was almost empty.
So I'm like, well I gotta have
another one and finish that one. Yeah.
Long story short,
one and a half of those plus the fucking
cores and I'm downstairs in my bed
talking Jibo's to my wife. I just meant
one point, she just goes from what?
And I was like, all right, time to go to
bed. So that one minor slip up, you know,
whatever. I think if you just did heroin
once a week, that wouldn't be bad. Right.
If you just did once,
you know,
maybe on the weekends he would want to
be nodding off at work. If I be bad.
That'd be hilarious. If you just
stuck to your guns, I'd be like, yeah,
four out of five days, I'm
fucking on it. One fucking day.
I come in here with track marks nodding
off of my cubicle and all of a sudden,
oh,
we need to have a meeting
that's an 80% it's a B minus.
Tell me your parents would ground
you over a B minus. They just say,
get your grades up. This is it.
Get your grades up, conversation.
Then I'm all about it.
But if you're going to start
saying that you're gonna fire me,
you're gonna fire me over a B
minus over a B minus. Okay. Yeah.
I'll get a fucking lawyer. I'll sue
the shit out of you, your honor.
My client was only doing
heroin once a week.
Okay. It was, it was the
middle of the week. It was a
Wednesday. Okay. Yuki came in.
He crushed it on Monday and Tuesday,
Wednesday.
Middly he wasn't worth anything
but Thursday and Friday. Right.
Finish strong.
We could equate this to a sports
analogy. He, uh, you know, uh,
when did, uh, when o for
20 and the beginning of the
third quarter. But anyway,
he came out with a victory.
Sorry. Um, anyways, yes. So I lost
four pounds his fucking week and, um,
I think I'm back on it. I, you know
what, I have an acting gig coming up,
so I got to get down to my
fighting weight. Is Bob Pogo?
Um,
is Dave Kempner was Bob Pogo says
my fighting weight is a one 72,
so I can drop three a week.
It's in two weeks.
I'll be down to like one
74 good. Three, four,
something like that.
And then I'll just fucking wean the
next two off while I do the shoot.
And there you go.
That's how it's done.
All right.
Oh, you fat actresses out there.
Fucking bitch. Moan and complain. Oh,
it's so easy for a fucking guy.
We got our fighting weight too.
You know,
so sick of that fucking myth that they put
out. Oh, guy can look however he wants.
Now, if you're a fat fuck, you're
going to play a fat fuck is a guy.
It's just just what it is.
You're going to play a fat fuck in.
The jokes are going to be
that you're a fat fuck, okay?
You're going to be doing a chip
and Dales dance with no shirt on.
You're going to be breaking coffee tables.
You'd be living in a
van down by the river.
You're going to be a mall cop
to tries to slide behind a pole,
but doesn't quite make it
because of the shape he's in.
Okay? I don't know what fucking
movies you're watching. Um,
and then the whole thing where they
sit there and they go, oh, you know,
I'm so sick of seeing these movies
where there's these guys in these,
these women, you know the, with
women half their fucking age. Well,
you know what that is, is because you
haven't traveled to where the money is.
Go Down in Miami,
you know, get out of the ugly parts of
the world like De Moines, Iowa. Okay,
I'll come on. You know, you're
ugly and if you're not ugly,
you're fucking planning an escape.
All the hot chicks move out at de Moines.
Where do they go? Cash. Cheyenne, Wyoming.
Yeah.
MMM.
You know,
then they meet some hot guy from Greeley
Nexeo there in Denver growing some
wheat.
Um, Greeley, we're having
a bad smell day. Um,
anyways, you know, a friend of mine
was just talking recently about this,
this farm that they have.
Uh,
they sponsored this farm somehow
somewhere out in England and they, um,
they don't kill the cows when
they stopped producing milk.
They just let them kind of just get old.
It's really cool.
It's like a cool farm man.
They milk the cows by hand.
I think all farms should do that. All
farmers should do that. And if there's,
you know, if they can't keep up with
the milk supply demand that, you know,
all that means is human beings will die.
And considering where the problem,
you know,
I say as long as it's not me or
anyone that I love, I'm all for it.
Here's something really fucked up.
Environmentally,
I started watching baseball again and
finally gave in, I bought the MLB package.
I'm S, I'm all set now. I've
got the center rice. I got
the fucking, what's this?
What's always got some dumb names?
They can't just say the NHL
against the center ice, the court,
sad fucking 50 yard line,
whatever they call them. Right?
I've got the Bruins to patriots,
Celtics and red.
So I've got the whole fucking thing.
And with my cable,
it just automatically renews,
which I love.
I usually don't like when it
automatically renews. Like, Hey, hey,
I make the decision now. I don't give a
shit. I'm just like gonna fine, whatever,
whatever. It's fine. Don't worry
about it. Um, so I've been watching,
uh, I watched that Rangers series.
I didn't realize how many Red Sox,
I didn't know.
He's Mookie Betts and right.
Yeah.
Bradley Jacob Jr,
something like that.
Yeah.
Bradley a a fucking Walmart
Junior, whatever the fuck
his name is. Milton Bradley.
What's his name? Something.
Bradley Jr, I dunno.
Then you got Andrew
[inaudible] and fucking left
Zan and Baguettes, Dustin Pedroia.
I don't know a lot of them.
Um, anyway, so I'm going to start watching
them and watching the Yankees too.
Cause Aaron, Judge Aaron Judge looks
like a fucking myth, doesn't he?
He looks like one of those fucking things
when they talk about baseball in the
early 19 hundreds, you know, and they
had those giant fucking, you know,
elephant Titus of the fucking hand
gloves that they use to play with.
You know, guy's fucking amazing. I
don't know what's going on though,
but I think baseball's numbers are down.
I think they do something whenever they,
whenever they fucking numbers go down,
I believe that they juice up the ball.
They've got to do something. I mean, it's
just all of a sudden, out of nowhere,
everybody just starts cranking
all these fucking home runs.
And this guy's on pace to hit like 60.
Um,
but anyways,
I've been not just sitting there
recording the games were in Tampa tonight,
right. We started, you know,
what happened was I went,
did that big papi roast and then
I went to the game and then I,
I just got back into it. I was like,
Oh yeah, I fucking love this game.
I forgot about that. Um,
and I think we went to, um,
Toronto.
I told I went to Toronto when
that series went to a ranger's,
right, Texas. Wait, this is
what I want to stand this.
What the fuck I was trying to get to was
I'm watching the fucking Texas Rangers.
They had that amazing ballpark.
I went there, I sat up,
I sat in the outfield because I wanted
to have the opportunity to run out on the
grass to try to get one of those
home runs, you know? And um,
yeah,
I've just found out that fucking ballpark.
It's not even 25 years old.
They're already, they're already
knocking it down, all that concrete,
all of that shit,
all of that fucking stuff.
Somebody please do a documentary and
followed the dump trucks and just show up.
Where does that go? What are they
going to do with all that? Fucking,
it's fine. It's fucking fine.
And like, well, you know,
it gets really hot out here in the summer.
We need a fucking real,
it gets hot out here in
the summer because of us.
We're a fucking plague.
Jesus Christ.
You already fucking Yag,
all that shit out of the Goddamn ground.
Now you just going to throw it out.
You're going to throw it in the
fucking ocean to build another one.
I don't know.
They're doing that in Atlanta.
Atlanta has a fucking ballpark.
That thing's not more than 25
years old. And they're like, well,
you knew our Fan Bay seeds GST.
You fart
dry cow.
[inaudible]
Aurelia,
right? They've got to bring it out to
where the white people are. All right?
White people, white people.
You don't have to do it.
And they're going to move it out
to the where the white people are.
You know what the problem is?
Is Atlanta Braves fans fucking suck.
They just lean on.
It's not even that they suck.
It's just they've had the ball yanked out
from underneath them a Zillion fucking
times. They've got Charlie
Brown. Okay, and then, you know,
after that last fucking Superbowl, if you
think these, these, these, these fucking,
I mean, if I was the president, I would
declare Atlanta a fucking disaster area.
If I was in Georgia,
all right?
I would just watch college
sports. Ibm, Georgia bulldogs.
That's what I would do. Georgia
tech, university of Georgia.
[inaudible] I didn't want to come
over and just slobber my fucking hand.
I'll go home and Jerrica up to the blog
and Georgia bulldog. Um, I would go,
that's disgusting. I will fuck
in. I would be into that shit.
Yeah.
So evidently they feel that not enough
black people come out. I have no idea.
This is just what people
from Atlanta told me.
They don't feel enough black people come
up or white people are too afraid to
drive their Chrysler town and country
countries and as SUVs into the greater
Atlanta area.
Yeah. MMM, okay.
To go to a fucking baseball game.
I have no idea.
So they're just abandoning that fucking
major league ballpark that some like
college team is now going to play
their baseball games and it's fucking
ridiculous. And then they're
going to build another one.
MMM.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I think you should have to
be in a ballpark for at least
50 fucking years. Right?
I, I'll be honest with you, I
couldn't believe how old those were.
I thought they made those
in like in the year 2000.
I thought they made them 2000 to meet
him like 94 or something like that. So,
um, I dunno. Who Cares?
You know who gives a fuck?
Just keep yanking the shit out of
the fucking ground building. Shit.
Rip It down and then throw it in the
ocean and then blame people with red ties
at Blue Tyson.
Then we'll just continue doing,
what the fuck would this depressing bill.
This is fucking depressing. All right.
How about some good news?
I have some of the best news I've
gotten in a long time. A long time.
All right. You ready for this? The
Indianapolis Colts got caught. Cheating.
Got caught cheating again.
Yeah,
it's fucking on. It's hilarious.
It's fucking hilarious.
How many of these fucking things that
these guys do and how little attention
those cunts at ESPN pay
attention to this shit.
The level of fucking focus on spy gate,
deflate gate,
all of this fucking shit. They're not
even going to do a story on ESPN like,
Hey,
wait a minute.
We spent two and a half years on fucking
deflate gate because the owner of a
team that's gotten caught
pumping in crowd noise,
fucking they haven't hearing aids now
I guess in the helmets because Peyton
manning was an or a new quarterback
and hadn't mastered the silent count.
The dude who caught the underinflated
fucking ball got busted doing roids.
They stole our fucking off fence.
I mean did they?
Yeah,
they get their owners sat
on the competition committee
and changes the rules of
passing to tip it in his favor so they
could beat the Patriots. It's fucking,
I believe this is a thing.
I'm not mad at any of that.
Okay.
Do you like,
does that make Indiana,
does that really make
them win the fucking game?
Cause they have hearing aids
in their fucking helmets.
I think that's fucking hilarious.
All right.
And I think it's the job of the league
to try to catch those people doing it.
And when people get caught,
I just laugh.
Okay.
Corked bats, all of that Shit's
funny. Steroids is the one thing.
Steroids. That's the one for me that
I feel that's the biggest thing.
You know, pumping in
crowd noise, hearing aids,
taking a context where the air out
of a ball trying to steal signs.
Jesus Christ. Everybody fucking,
but that shit's hilarious to me.
And those are some of the best stories
that you hear when you listen to pro
athletes. Half their fucking funny
stories are about guys cheating.
Was every time a rough turns it's
can I keep punching me in the ball?
So I'm just like, dude, what
the fuck? By the third quarter,
my balls are the size of my fucking head.
So I turned around and I kicked him in
the nuts from behind. I get his taint,
his fucking ass out. Like every
one of them, you go to a banquet,
all of their fucking stories are about
the shit that they did to each other when
the refs warrant looking.
Um, my only one is steroids.
That's the only one I
give a fuck about it.
If you get caught using
steroids just because that,
you know,
and that doesn't make you throw the
ball farther or see it better or get bat
speed or any of that shit. It just
keeps you feeling brand fucking new.
You're going up there like
you got eight hours sleep,
like you never got tackled in your life.
Like you never got hit on the
rib cage by a fast ball. It just,
you like a fucking x
man. That's the one. Yes.
MMM.
Dan. I look at like what the fuck? But
I also, I also understand it. I mean,
cause at least in football,
like what those guys do to their bodies
and what happens to their brains at the
very least. I mean, I think they ought
to be able to heal up like x men.
I think they ought to
be able to smoke weed.
Yeah.
You know, at a state level so
they don't get in trouble. Yeah.
Um, that's the only thing. Um,
but listen to the ting colts.
I don't think Peyton Manning's a cheater.
I don't think the cults
of fucking cheaters,
I think it's fucking hilarious
that you got caught doing that.
Just because your owner is a cunt.
He's such a fucking content.
I can't believe that ESPN is just
gonna fucking ignore this story.
They just ignoring the thing. Quick
little blurb. Bing, Bang, boom. Done.
See you later.
Okay.
There's no, Hey, wait a minute. Yeah.
The all time this guy was saying by the
bed, the bed. Meanwhile he's doing this.
I mean, Jesus Christ. ESPN
is the dog days of summer.
God knows you've got to fill
up some fucking airtime.
There's a patriots fan.
Can you at least have Bob Lee do
some fucking outside the line? Shit.
They won't do it. They won't
fucking do whatever. Whatever.
What are you going to do?
I love it though.
I love it because to this day I
still get shit when I was up in, um,
when I was up in Porchester
fucking giant fans,
giant fans who had former great giants
talk about fucking cheating all the time,
all the shit that they do like,
like this fucking Guy Jim or say succeeded
because he in his own weight tainted,
ah,
the Patriots when they did absolutely
nothing more than anybody else's fucking
do it,
which is basically
fucking grab as bullshit and they're
acting like they're fucking, I dunno.
I Dunno. I Dunno. I don't get it. I
don't fucking get it. You know what?
I just Tom Brady,
he's just too good looking.
If Tom Brady looked like pate manning,
I'm telling you right now this way,
and we weren't winning championships.
It wouldn't be a fucking story,
but whatever.
All I know is I got another round of
ammunition that I can put in the gun any
fucking time anybody speaks up,
um,
about the patriots cheat. Die. What do
you think about the Indianapolis Colts?
Huh?
Hey, how do you feel about the, uh,
the Falcons or the, uh, the Vikings?
What do you think about those guys?
Uh,
what do you think about
the Pittsburgh Steelers?
What do you think the New York football
giants, what do you think about Ndi?
You don't think anything about that?
You know why?
Because Espn didn't tell you
to think anything about it.
You fucking buffalo wild wings,
mouth breathe and far let it go below.
Right. I am. Anyways,
a buddy of mine was just brought up that
Conor McGregor Mayweather fight again
and uh, it was fucking
hilarious. And he goes,
you don't think Mcgregor has a chance?
And I'm just like, I think he's, you know,
I told him I go there. I think he's
had an unbelievable disadvantage.
You know what I mean?
He's like a,
he's like a fucking swimmer and
this is like a fighter. And I,
that's a bad analogy. I don't know
what it is. I told you the analogy,
it's like fucking Tom Brady, Jerry Rice
at the height of their fucking careers.
Let's see.
What's a better football player by seeing
who can throw the football further and
more accurate. That's the only level
of competition. So this guy's gone.
You don't think he's got a chance.
He goes,
look at his boxing in this and
he shows me a fucking MMA fight.
The guy throws like three punches and
then a flying fucking knee and takes the
guy to the ground is just like,
dude, that's not boxing. All right.
World class championship boxers could
not lay a fucking glove on this guy.
These not going to be
able to land a fucking,
I don't need an Atlantic love on them.
The only change,
the only thing he has is if Mayweather,
I dunno,
in the last,
whenever the last time you fought was
he just got old like Jordan between the
bowls in the wizards.
Like he just had a noticeable fucking
drop off and he can somehow rough the guy
up. And I know Mayweather's hands are
fucked up from all the years of fucking
punching guys in the head.
Um,
okay,
well maybe he can fucking somehow getting
Mayweather's ego into like you can
talk enough shit that
MMA is a superior sport
that may,
whether is it going to want to knock
them out and maybe he comes in and do and
for the first time in his
career does something stupid.
I just don't see it happening.
Um,
I said that I hate this fight cause
I know I'm going to order it. But um,
after the debate with him and watching
him sending me an MMA clip to show me how
good this guy was at boxing,
mmm.
Am now, but I don't think I'm going to
order the fucking thing. I'm gonna wait,
I'm gonna wait to people call me up and
seal and I mean wait for text of like,
Oh shit. Capital Letters.
Then I'll order it.
Or if they go, that was a
complete fucking waste of money,
then I'll just laugh and then
I'll probably, we'll order it.
I'm going to order it. God Damn
fucking Shit. I'm going to order it.
I'm going to give Mayweather another
hundred. You know, nobody's fucking money.
That guy owes me,
wants you to fight Manny Pacquiao fucking
10, 11 years after when he should have.
Although I actually, I mean I thought
that that guy was on something, you know,
you know, I know, cause
I'm not in the fight game.
Anytime a guy just keeps moving up in
weight class and he just keeps getting
stronger. I mean, is that possible?
I moved up in weight class. I went
up to him. What you a buck 90.
I didn't get any faster. Um, anyways,
let's read some fucking advertising here
and then I have to go into the writer's
room for season three of f is for family.
Oh boy.
Another 10 episodes.
Um,
and I am being a fucking angel,
an angel as far as my eating
in that writer's room. Nothing.
Nothing will fuck you over like
sitting in a goddamn writer's room.
You sitting on your ass all fucking day
and his candy and chips and chips and
candy and pizza and fucking
burgers and fries. I mean,
it is, it is. It's fucking, you might
as well be sitting in a crack house.
Um, this k here's my diet. All right
here for me. I feel like this works.
All right. I have oatmeal, third of
a cup of oatmeal with a bunny in it.
Right. A little bit of milk in there to
cool off the fucking, the the fucking,
I don't know what it is. And Fuck
you guys with your steel cut oats.
I don't give a shit. This works for
me. All right. Then I have two eggs.
Oish that's it. Right? Then between
lunch and breakfast, I have an orange.
That's it. And then for lunch, I have
some sad fucking salad with the protein.
No bread. And then I just crush
waters. I leave around five,
I gotta eat something else in
the afternoon. I don't know what.
And then I come home and I have a salad
with a protein and I do a half hour of
cardio and a, that's it.
The fat has nowhere to hide.
It's like a fucking roach. When you
turn the lights on, it's just freezes.
It doesn't know what to do and
then it's dead. That's it. Um,
and I just have to, what I have to
do is I have to stick with this.
So I'm down to just under one 80.
I'm a buck 79 and change.
So this time next week I want when
I'm in fucking grand rapids, Michigan,
during my favorite fucking
gigs in the country,
the Fountain Street fucking Church,
um,
I'm doing some fun gigs
coming up by the way. Uh,
I want to be one 76 next week is
what I'm saying. Um, but uh, I got a,
I'm playing that fucking venue,
that buddy Holly,
the big bopper and Ritchie
Valens all played the night.
They died flying into the same fucking
airport and now you guys are saying,
oh Geez, Bell, don't
judge your work. No, no,
because we actually have de icing exists.
They did not have that. All
right. Legal Zoom, everybody.
And that kid is going to be like in a
November I and it's not on sale yet as far
as I know.
All right.
Legal Zoom in order to successfully run
your own business attention to detail is
so critical.
One contract slip up,
one contract slip up or illegal
misunderstanding can really set you back.
Fortunately, there's legal zoom. You may
already know that over a million billion,
billion Americans have used
zoom to start their business,
but legal zoom services go
well beyond business formation.
They built a nationwide
network of independent
attorneys who can provide legal
answers to the day to day questions
you have about your business.
What the fuck is this man?
Because let's face it,
things like trademarks,
employment laws and lease agreements
can get pretty complicated,
so don't waste your valuable
time trying to wrap you up.
Simple little head around,
all the fine print.
Use Legal Zoom for that so you can
focus on growing your business. Instead,
you'll get the legal help you need
without being billed by the hour.
Since legal zoom isn't a law firm,
go to legalzoom.com today and
be sure to enter Code Burb,
B U R R in the referral box for special
savings only@legalzoom.com oh look who's
here, but Oh, don't do me ids behind
these. The cults used here in a,
they do do. Dude. Mandy's me
undies, that aid Gado raid.
They fucking cheated.
You're a bunch of cunts.
You got on me undies to take a dump bed.
Your balls feel good with your silent
count. You fucking hypocritical.
Cons. Oh yeah. Five
fucking rings. Go suck it.
All right me undies. Ah Man, I, that's
my one of my favorite one ever be on ds.
What's the first thing you put on
and the last thing you take off? Huh?
It's not your socks. You fucking
Weirdo. It's your underwear.
Make your most important piece of clothing
the best it can be with me on this.
What is me undies? You might've
asked. Oh, just seriously soft.
Feel good undies delivered
right to your door.
Me undies are designed in La and made
from sustainably sourced that micro modal,
modal,
a fabric three times softer than cotton.
You know what? I think my stomach's
three times softer than micro molder.
Mandy is softer than soft.
Luxury undies comes in an ever
changing selection of classic colors.
Bold shades.
What are classic colors?
Does that like your first box of crayons
where you just have the eight colors,
bold shades and adventurous patterns.
So you can tailor your undies to your
own personal style. And guess what?
You can save time and money each
month with a monthly subscription.
And if you're not ready for
a subscription, that's okay.
This is great monthly subscription.
You know,
you keep dressing up your
junk in a different way.
It seems new to your wife, right? All
of a sudden she's dropping to her knees,
putting her Edith Wharton book on
the fucking nightstand. Go into town.
And guess what?
You can save time and money each
month with a monthly subscription.
If you're not ready for a subscription,
that's okay. You can still say,
that's because me undies is offering
you 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burr
and get 20% off your first pair.
So go revamp your underwear drawer.
You deserve it.
You did serve it once again.
That's [inaudible] dot com
slash [inaudible] dot com
slash [inaudible] all right,
let's finish with this.
Um, how bout those fucking
Celtics de de,
De, De, De, De, any age, age, age,
angels. That word number that Larry
Bird buried Byard by [inaudible]. Um,
he's making some fucking moves. I guess
we're going after this. Gordon Haywood.
Everybody thinks he's a great fit
for the Boston Celtics because one,
he's a great player too. He played for
coach Brad Stevens at Butler and Trey.
He's fucking, yeah. Why?
Why, why? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Celtics love a white guys
still love a white guy.
Boudou Tu Tu Tu Tu Tu Tu boop, boop, boop.
I don't know what it is. The Celtics,
they just have to have the white guy. I
watched this. We played Utah. I didn't,
I didn't see what the big fucking deal
was. Everybody's sleeping on my God. Go.
This guy is fucking unreal.
He's white like me. Um, Jason Tatum,
we got Jason Tatum Dry,
drafted him.
I saw him play at Duke last
year against Carolina. You know,
I think he's a great fit for the Celtics.
You know,
we played at Duke on to coach k is an
absolute beast and he appears to be at
least tap white. He's light
skinned did. There you go.
That's Celtics like that.
I'm fucking with you guys.
Um,
look at fucking daddy age becoming
like a fucking red Roi back.
Junior's got all these draft picks.
He's fucking wheel and he's dealing,
you know what?
I want to see him do.
I want to see him light up a
fucking so you can't do it anymore.
Light up a fucking cigar when we're
up by 20 in the fourth quarter.
Just light it up. It's fucking over red.
Our back used to do that on the bench.
I mean, just one of the
biggest shit talkers ever
without having to say one word.
Oh my God. How bad did people
want to beat that guy? Um,
all right. Anyways, that's going to be the
podcast for this week. Oh, you know what?
I bought some new symbols.
I got a bunch of new symbols.
I finally get the jazz ride that I wanted.
I still fucking suck,
but my cymbal sound great.
And um,
I'm still my Gretsch kit that I ordered.
I ordered it and may,
they said it'd take two and a half months.
So it's been a month and a half. So, uh,
it should be here at any moment now,
Bill, it should be here in another month.
If you do the math,
whatever.
I know what's going to happen when I
fucking leave to New York and I go to do
the acting gig. That's when it's going
to fucking show up. Murphy's law.
And then I'm going to come here and
then we'll be like, sorry we missed you.
And they're going to be like,
we don't know where the drum
kit is. Uh, you know, we,
we set it down,
right?
And then I'm going to fucking see some
street performer with my fucking Gretsch
kit and I'm going to know it's mine cause
it's going to have three floor toms,
like fucking doesn't that could have
one rack, Tom, three floor toms,
the triangle of death to my right.
Um,
I'm already going to order
another rack, Tom. I think, uh,
I'm just doing everything I can to have
a different fucking set up so I can get
out of my 30 year fucking John Bonam
vortex that I went down and um,
I've been playing the double pedal.
I've been playing a double panel to
Primus and a low and a little bit of Pan
Tara.
I'm just doing whatever I can listen to
the lung and then slowing it down and
fucking trying to get my
shit up to speed. And, and I,
you've been listening to
like 1950s miles Davis.
Typical me fucking add all over the map.
Why,
why work at one of those things at one
time so you can actually get something
down bill when you can work
at with at all of it at once.
All of it at once. Um, all right.
Whatever I'm having. What the fucking,
I mean I'm not a pro or you know, I'm
not going to be recording anything soon.
Who gives a fuck?
I'm going to record anything ever.
Okay.
Yeah. Although, you know, I've
been doing the, I did that video,
that Sunday video podcast.
I had a great time doing that. I'm
going to do those every once in a while.
Maybe one of these times.
Yeah. I'll fucking,
I'll do like a Nah,
I can't do a drought to a little clip.
I'll put a little clip up.
MMM [inaudible]
I got to do a drum cover of like
one of the worst songs ever.
And then just be sitting there cause it
has to, I have to somehow make you laugh,
right. I can't just do a drum
cover and be like, yeah, Bill,
why don't understand what the purpose
of that was. What am I watching?
The banana splits is like fucking
danger island going to come on next.
MMM.
Oh maybe I'll just do
one behind the drum kit.
I'll just talk shit for fucking half hour.
And then the second I'm done,
I can play drums.
Maybe that's how I do it.
And I act like I'm going to play drums,
but then I never do.
And then you like bill, what the fuck? And
I'll just be like, no, what the fuck you,
because I made you watch until the
end. I'm like, Bill, Bill. Yeah.
Beer right now playing a mind game.
We used to play mind games with
people. Um, is that what you did bill?
I thought you just waited to people
left the ground and you took the fucking
legs out from underneath them.
I didn't realize that that was some,
it was a holiday on a level
of mental shit going on there.
I thought you just understood gravity
and somebody being vulnerable. All right,
that's the podcast. Go fuck yourselves.
Uh, God bless the Indianapolis Colts.
Not everybody having been
through this as a patriots fan.
I want you to be nice to those colts fans.
Do not call them cheaters.
It isn't fair.
Um,
fucking hearing aid status. Hilarious.
Could they talk to each other?
Do you realize how fucking funny that is?
Yeah.
And that you sit in there and your
offensive line coach comes in. I listen.
This kid ain't fucking making man.
He doesn't know what the fuck he's still,
we're going to get her assets. It's
going to be allowed building. All right?
Just put these fucking things in.
Okay.
Anything,
any one of them sat there going like,
but coach isn't that against the rules?
That's fucking hilarious.
I love that they did that.
That's one of my favorite things
about sports, you know, is that shit.
Somebody with Vaseline
under their fucking did.
That guy had the shit on his
neck and it's just fucking funny.
And then everybody judges him.
Like you never drove in the car pool
lane without another person in the car.
Right?
You never cheated on a test.
You never fucked around on your
girlfriend or your boyfriend, you know,
fucked around in your taxes.
Huh?
You have a cut in line.
We're all fucking cheaters.
You cons fucking holier than
now douche bags. All right.
Um,
yeah.
Anyways,
let me look as,
unless you're doing like steroids or
like you making somebody, you know,
you're fucking somebody over on a house
and then they're upside down in the
house and you fucked them over for life.
And then their senior citizens,
they have to eat Paul.
That's when,
that's when you got to step in and do
something. But other than that, you know,
you bust somebody and then you
fucking laugh at him. You know,
you never cheated on your diet.
You fucking spouse walks in.
Did you got a fucking
spoon for the ice cream,
ms your cook bat right in your fucking
mouth. All right, go fuck yourselves.
I have a great weekend. Your
content. I'll see you on Monday.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
oh yeah, the Monday morning podcast. We
have our own Twitter account. Finally,
if you'd like to follow the MN podcasts
and get the links for all the, uh,
videos and all this
stuff that I talk about,
follow us here at the and podcasts.
Um,
our Twitter handle is at the m m p a
podcast at the m m podcasts and m m p is
all capitalized solar power.
Everybody can I take five minutes
just to be a fucking hippie man.
Um, every once in awhile I go in
and out of my fucking, you know, um,
with the team and now and then, and
then I'm against the team, you know,
kind of like a fucking,
uh, like a Randy Moss,
you know, you come into town,
you got your mind right.
And after about a season and a half,
you start acting like a fucking maniac.
That's how I feel when I look at,
uh, whatever the fuck and explore.
I was really trying to avoid the
expression, the powers that be,
but um,
I dunno,
I can't help it every time when I land
in Los Angeles and I look out at the
basin is as they call it,
I'm from the San Gabriel mountains
all the way south of that,
which is fucking La and greater la,
all of that,
just what an absolute clusterfuck it is.
And um,
what happens when the shit hits the fan?
So I'm thinking about getting some solar
panels and I know all your rednecks out
there saying the obvious thing to fuck
good. Just solar panel going to do.
If you ain't got a gun,
what are you going to keep the guy warm
that fucking shoots you in the head and
steals you provisions.
I understand they're fucken
bearded wonder. All right,
I get it.
But one step at a time.
One step at a fucking time. First
thing I want to do, I want to get,
you know, it's ridiculous.
I live in a fucking desert.
The House bakes in the sun
and I'm s I still have,
I don't have solar powered. It's
the dumbest shit ever. So, uh,
I'm going to look into it and I want,
I want to know is, is, you know,
is that two types of solar power.
There's one,
will you still on the grid and then
there's one where you're off the grid.
I like off the grid and if
anybody's listening to my podcast,
if you're off the grid, like
what happens? Did they like it?
Do they get mad at you?
I mean, how do they know? Because all
of a sudden you've bill goes down.
Does that like set off a light,
you know,
and underneath the mountain that all
those Illuminati guys live in and then
somebody pulls up to your house.
Say,
I noticed you haven't been
making any toast lately.
And uh, you know, what's going on here?
How come you're not watching TV?
What are you reading books in their
fucking eating apples off the tree.
How come you're not using any electrical,
uh, tricity there. Does that happen?
Is it a, it's not illegal to be off
the grid. They just sort of fucking a,
do they bully you at all? Like, just
let me know what I'm in for. All right.
Because what I would love to do is it
continue spending legal tender that really
has nothing behind it other than the
faith of every freckled face can't over
here. Um, I would really love
to continue existing in this,
but I would like to have the backup that
if the shit does hit the fan before I'm
overrun by a mob,
you know,
because mine's the only light on
the top of the hill. See, that's,
I used to do a bit about that. That's
the thing, like if you actually have,
if you're off the grid, all right? And
everything just goes fucking haywire.
You immediately, you got to cut
your lights out quick. Okay?
Cause the first thing when everybody
loses power, they stand. They go, Oh,
you've got to be fucking shitting me.
I was watching two brokers Olvey right?
That's the first thing
you flipped the switches is it?
Then this, you know, within 30 seconds
you're like, is it just our house?
And you look out the window.
So you basically,
you have 30 fucking seconds
to cut all your lights off.
I'm tell you wife to shut the
fuck up and get downstairs.
Then that little corner room,
all right?
You put your hand on a shoulder
firmly.
You don't hurt him,
but you're not affectionate.
You place your hand on her shoulder
so she knows it's impertinent.
Fucking information is on
the way. Can you say, honey,
we're the only ones left. We're the
only ones left. Look at me. Stop crying.
We're the only ones with the only ones
left with power and I need you to hold it
together.
Cried out.
Now I want you to cry every
ounce of bitch you have in you,
out of you in this corner of this house.
Okay?
And when you come upstairs,
I want you to sit here and act
like we do not have power. Okay?
So when the Sullivan's come across the
fucking street and see if we don't have
power,
why did their fucking faces
honey,
forget about the cell phones.
They're not going to make you understand.
You know,
I don't want that to happen.
I don't want that to happen to anybody,
but I don't want to be the Sullivan.
You know what I mean?
I want a shot. Just give me a
fucking shot. That's all I need.
I just need some solar panels and a
fucking helicopter and I will get the fuck
outta here. That's what you need.
You fucking 80 [inaudible] guns,
Huh? What do you Schwartzenegger
how long is that? Gonna last. Um,
anyways, so I'm thinking about it. Does
anybody, is anybody live in the La area?
Does anybody have solar panels anywhere
in the fucking world? Can you recommend,
are there two different kinds?
Because I actually looked up
solar panels off the grid and a,
I came to this place,
a blue Pacific solar,
it says off grid packages.
Um,
then there's another one that
just says get solar power,
Sun power off grid systems.
Off Grid System.
Backwoods solar electric systems.
Yeah,
I kinda stole that Shit.
Whoa, Whoa, whoa.
We're gonna do is we're going to bring
it in and we'll just run it over the
outhouse.
Well, what go ban on what's that? A cigar.
I'm
sorry.
I'm going a stupid fucking
mode this week. Um, yeah. Oh,
then there's one for Australia.
I don't mind paying the grid,
but I would like to have, if
the grid fails to have the
then off the grid switch.
How about that?
Can we just have that,
those of you who've been
on the Internet this week,
you know the direction that I'm working.
Oh yes. You'd do this. Stop being modest.
You know the direction I'm going in.
I'm talking about solar fucking Rhodes.
Has anybody seen this, this youtube
video? It's fucking amazing if,
if what they're saying is true
about these solar roads. Um,
and I apologize for the narrator.
I get what he's doing.
He's trying to keep it interesting,
but he kept in interesting too long and
then he brings it down to an interlude,
which should have come a minute earlier
and then he goes back to screaming.
So it's a little bit annoying, but, uh,
just try to listen to the information
and then try not to get sucked into a
George Bush Obama debate because,
uh,
I dunno, I dunno if these things, what
the fuck do I know? Right. But it just,
they were basically saying if we replaced
all our roads with these solar fucking
things that literally look,
makes it look like Lego land and it's
all lit up and there'd be sensors to let
you know,
a deer is going around the corner and
then it would just light up in the turn a,
there's a fucking deer around the corner,
you know,
enjoy your barley pancakes or whatever.
Right.
For some fucking full on Hippie Shit.
And that basically the amount of energy
that it would create would be three
times what this country even needed,
which immediately we can just
leave the Middle East. Right.
We don't have to be over there pissing
them off by getting in the middle of
their bullshit.
All right.
We don't have to deal with oil and oil.
Money is what funds the terrorist as
far as my limited reading goes. Right.
The, the, the families over there
that, fuck, hang on, she's scratching.
I just gave you a bath.
What's wrong? Oh wait.
Oh. Um, anyways, uh,
yeah, like the fucking the oil people over
the people who make all the money over
there.
They then donate to mosques and
then in the moss they fucking,
you know, kind of fucking a, you know,
send it over to these
fucking people over here.
That ended up coming back at US
shooting shit at us as far as you know,
like I said, I don't know shit.
Cleo, would you stop fucking,
you're going to have to go to the other
room here. Come here buddy. What's up?
Sweden? We went on a nice hike today,
didn't we? Huh? Good food. Good.
All right. Get out of
here. Um, so anyways, um,
yeah, and then that whole fucking
thing is just null and void.
We have all this extra power actually.
Do we create a bunch of jobs?
The only thing I don't
know is the way it looks.
It doesn't seem like it's a smooth ride.
It just seems like the whole
time he'd be gone. Hello?
Like over these fucking things. I
have no idea, but just check it out.
And I swear to God, because
this is something that I
don't know if it, if it is,
if it does work, if it does fucking
work, it could benefit everybody.
Conservatives, liberals, independence,
everybody who wouldn't benefit from
all of this energy. All that's right.
The people in power. Ah. How
could I forget that? That's real.
How do you think that they're going to
derail this if this actually becomes a
movement,
how will they somehow tie in terrorism?
Nine 11 liberals fucking right wing
conservatives and just get this,
the pot fucking stern. So everybody's
screaming and yelling, let's go. Let me.
Hell of an ugly, expensive,
and had babies will starve.
They're going to do all of that shit.
Um,
the only way this thing gets
off the ground, if it works,
if it works,
is if people don't get sucked into those
arguments and we all become one and we
all pick up a hatchet and we start
marching towards the bankers.
Gated communities. Okay?
Because the asphalt streets,
we'll have to run red with blue blood
money before something wonderful like this
will ever fucking happen
because you are fucking with
a century and a half of cashflow
going to a small amount of people,
that's what you're fucking with. And when
you're fucking was something like that,
that level of money, basically the
money that gives the dollar power,
like the only thing gives the u s dollar
powers that oil barrels of oil are
still measured in US dollars. Other
than that, it's a fucking shit show.
So these guys are the
guys behind all of that.
It's them in the fucking bankers
and that's it. All right.
The insurance companies like the Ted
Kennedy or that fucking family. All right.
But fucking Bobby and Jack.
All right.
Actually the banks have
fun, Joe Kennedy. All right,
they'll shut up with the Kennedy Shit.
All right. So anyways, that's my thing.
Like this is a great fucking
idea. If it works, if it works,
it's a fucking great idea.
Even if you just did a few roads,
if you just did a few of them,
each state just did like their
main highway or whatever.
You just did that.
I can't imagine the amount of of money
we'd save and on the less than, Oh man,
it was incorrect.
The possibilities of it are incredible.
I don't know if it works, but it is
fucking incredible. But the sad thing is,
um, the fact that whenever
new stuff like this comes up,
it all just turns into a Obama Bush,
Republican, Democrat, blah, blah, blah.
Everybody's just yelling at each other
and then it just fucking goes away.
And then everybody turns on sports and
that's what happens. So there you go.
This is all off the grid,
Billy. 15 minutes of crazy talk.
But that makes sense to me. Makes
sense to me, man. Fuck, you know,
we get this done. Everyone was
so, so, so fucking wear bro. Oh,
Liam liberals out there in Hollywood.
Right. And I gotta tell you, I'm the, I'm,
I'm not just making fun of
stereotypical southern guy. All right?
Because having lived
out here in Hollywood,
these people are out of their fucking mind
state. They have Fox News to the left.
They're out of their fucking minds that
there does such fucking hypocrites where
it's just like, you can say the most, uh,
I guess racist isn't the word.
Cause you can make fun of white people,
rich white people. You can
basically, you can be a,
you can use the exact fucking thing
that they don't like seeing used on poor
people against rich people. And
they fucking love it. You know,
you can suggest that people
from the south or all fucking,
they're sisters and they're slapping
their knees and they're doing the wave and
the crowd.
All right.
But if you suggest any homeless guy
needs to get off his fucking ass,
stop boozing and get a fucking
job, then you're the devil. So
I mean, I dunno, does that make
any sense? We'll, it shouldn't.
Isn't that why you're
listening to this podcast?
[inaudible]
solar panels last week,
like I talked
about, I was thinking about maybe
getting solar panels off my house,
off my house on my house.
And uh,
I don't know if I want to go off the grid,
but whatever city of Bacon in
the sun in this fucking house,
that might as well get something out
of it. Right. All right, so here we go.
Hi Bill. First off, huge fan of
your comedy podcasts. Thank you.
I saw you for a Brian Regan.
Oh, with Brian Regan cobb's
comedy. While that was a,
that was a bucket list at night for me
to be able to perform with that guy show
was absolutely hilarious. Well thank you.
And thank you from Brian Regan to um,
anyway,
regarding your question about solar,
there is no solar power that
is completely off the grid.
You use all the energy that you can
provide through solar and the rest that
can't be provided by the sun like at
night or if it gets shady on your roof.
The utility provides, this is
called interconnection. Uh,
you save a ton of money and you
use clean energy in the process.
I worked for a solar company.
I promise this isn't a bullshit sales
pitch and I manage the construction
timeline,
so I've learned a lot about this stuff.
Here's a link to my company I worked for.
We install a lot in la
and in Boston as well too.
I think we're in like 12 different states.
Anyways,
thanks you for the awesome podcast and
you know something about this Psoas Shit.
This, every person you talk
to says something different.
I watch people on Youtube
make up a solar thing. Um,
what a solar thing.
Put up their solar panels broke
down how they worked and uh,
and how you could get off the
grid, but it was really, really,
really fucking involved.
This guys dig in a goddamn trench.
I can't remember what the fuck was
going on, but I'm just like, all right,
I don't have room for a trench. All
right. My little piece of property here.
So I and I, you know, I got room
for a whole, does that work?
I can't even what he was doing,
they dug this trench,
the stuff like a fucking tarpon there.
I don't even know what the heck.
I can't even tell you what's going
on. But um, I will definitely,
I'll definitely look into it.
Um,
hopefully I'll have
more luck with you guys.
And the fucking constant put the
roof on this house. Fucking assholes.
I told you what they did right.
They put the roof on the house
and then like the drain pipes,
because it's an old house,
old stupid design with a drain off was
it goes down into a pipe that actually
goes into like, uh, I don't, I have
like, uh, my attic is actually,
you ever see seen John Malcovich or being,
being John Malcovich remember they
had that floor, we had to walk around,
bent over. Like that's basically
how much space there is between, um,
the ceiling on my top
floor and then the roof.
I don't even know what the purpose
of it is. All it is is just,
it just traps air that gets heated up and
causes my house to be hot. But anyways,
that's what it is.
So the drain off of the water on the
roof goes into a pipe that goes in,
into the fucking crawl space and then
back out the front of the house and down
the side. So you take water from the
roof, you bring it into the house,
it's inside a pipe,
but nevertheless you bring it into the
fucking house and God forbid that pipe
bursts or you have some fucking moron
who disconnects it when he's putting the
new roof on and forgets to hook it back
up and then tries to blame an yeah,
he blamed it on mobile, you know, the
fucking, all the blah, blah, blah.
And I'm just sitting there going, all
right, this is at least a year in court.
You know what? Why don't you
just get the fuck out of here?
I'll just put in a goddamn claim.
You can't.
That's what I did because I didn't
want to go to court. So, um, anyways,
I'm hoping you, you're better than
those guys. I mean, how couldn't you be?
All right. Here's my favorite one.
This week a solar roadways debunked.
MMM.
I got a note from my gay here,
Andrew says a ton of people forwarded
the same link as the one in the email
below. I watched this so you don't
have to, it's 30 minutes long.
Basically he bitches about cost and
maintenance and the efficiently if
efficiency of the perks,
advertising original video like heating,
repairing the road. Yeah, I actually
watched the first 10 minutes of it.
Um, I'll save my opinion until I read
this. Uh, Yo Billy, the sunburned kit.
I know you were pretty pumped up about
solar roads is be honest. So was I,
but someone's smart sat down
and crunched some numbers,
invite up points as well as to why
solar roads are economically in tech.
Technically not feasible.
It's about 30 minutes long.
So if you've got some time to kill
in any airport, check it out. Well,
you know what sir, I watched the first 10
minutes of it. Uh, he didn't debunk them.
He just brought up a bunch of questions.
He's just like a road has to be durable
and I would have some questions about,
I mean,
they showed a tractor run over the tiles,
but it was a small tractor
and they only did it once. Um,
I would like to see how these,
you know,
these things hold up when it's wet
out and you need water to run off.
And he just brought up a bunch
of fucking questions. You know,
he didn't debunk them.
He did basically basically what he did,
it's like 50% what you have to do. You
can have somebody just come in and, hey,
these are brand new roads. Can I make
them? Oh, okay. You think they're good,
you think they're going to work okay.
I mean, obviously you can't do that,
but it's 50% that, which is smart.
You gotta ask the right questions.
And then the other side is anytime
you try to do something new,
there's always people saying
it's not gonna work. You know,
and this guy in his half hour,
I'm sure he brought,
he brought up a number of
things that would be a problem.
It doesn't mean they can't
work. Okay. So I don't,
I wouldn't say they would debunked.
I would just say somebody asked a bunch
of fucking questions and rather than
just when what he does is he just
throws it out there. It's like,
why don't you contact the people at the
solar road who tried to make the solar
roads and actually get some
answers and get some fucking, uh,
or maybe ordered some tiles and tried
to do some experiments yourself rather
than wasting people's time with a half
hour of questions and speculation.
That's basically what it was. So I
wouldn't say that it was debunked. Um,
but you know, you throw up three
pointers for a half an hour,
some of them are going
to go in if you suck.
So I'm sure a couple of his concerns
were true, but uh, you know,
let me look at electric cars
since way back in the day.
People, they show up, they're fucking up.
Like people actually questioned
the power of electric electricity.
It powers the entire fucking city
can light up a whole fucking city.
And I get a Prius and my own mother,
my own mother is going,
can it go up a hill?
No mom,
I just got to get out and start walking.
It's great for my weight.
And look at that. They say,
oh they're underpowered and
their this and their that.
First of all,
the Prius is not an electric car.
It's not even a fucking 50% electric car.
It's like an 8% electric car.
That's what it is from like zero.
I've told you this guys for years
from zero to seven miles an hour,
that car runs on electric power and then
switches over to gas for the rest of
the time.
And if you drive with a lead foot,
you're going to get maybe 25
miles a gallon. But if you listen,
you listen to the engine,
okay.
And you don't stomp on the gas and drive
like a fucking maniac and slam on the
brakes. You can get, you know, I don't,
I wouldn't say 40 miles a gallon.
You can get like 35 but it's great.
Perfect car if you live in, in the city.
I absolutely love the fucking
thing. So anyway, so you had that.
I bought that thing in October
of 2007 and now look at these,
these Tesla cars. I actually
wrote in one of those, uh,
the end of last year before I wrote in
Casey's fucking truck, Jesus Christ,
which probably gets two feet
to the gallon, especially
the way he was driving it.
Um, those Tesla cars that are, are,
are fucking amazing and you can drive
from last I checked from San Diego,
all you have to Vancouver,
um,
you know they have a recharge
stations from San Diego.
All we have to Vancouver and I think
recently someone just drove one across the
country. So it's not like that guy
in the speculation video. Um, I'm,
I got to look that one up or you
should look it up or whatever. But um,
I'm actually, uh, I'm leaning towards
that fucking thing. Thanks Badass.
You walk up to,
when you turn it on,
like the door handles are flush against
the car and you walk up and things pop
out. Sure. Other cars do that,
but I never seen it, you know?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hey,
what's going on and spill bar and it is
the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
June the sixth,
2009.
And this is my last couple of
days here in New York City.
I can't wait to get back to,
uh,
to Los Angeles even though
everybody fucking trashes that city.
I'd never lived in a city where so many
people so openly just fucking trash it.
You know what I mean? It's weird.
Hey, where do you live? Oh,
I lived in a, I live in Saint
Paul, Minnesota. Oh my God,
that place sucks. Those people
are so fucking phony. Yeah.
Have another contrived snowball
fight, you know, I dunno,
whatever.
And people always,
I love when people go to fucking La is
they go down to fucking right on the
sunset strip and then they fucking talk
about how Hollywood and phony it is.
Really.
When you go to Georgia,
do you go to Atlanta or do you go
to like fucking Macon, Georgia?
And they'd be like,
I can't believe how many of you,
I can't believe how many
rednecks there were there.
What you fucking went to ground
zero of it yet? Dumb fuck.
Um,
I'm grumpy this week.
I'm grumpy this week cause uh,
I don't want to fucking be here anymore.
I just realized that I don't
want to be here anymore,
which is great because this
is my last day of shooting.
I am having a great time
when I am on the set,
but when I am off to set and I'm trying
to figure out what the fuck I do in a
city that I already lived in
for 12 fucking years, you know,
what am I going to get another slice?
Am I going to go to central park
for the 90th million fucking times.
90 million fucking time is
what I'm trying to say there.
I was drinking yesterday and
like the afternoon, you know,
went into watch the red sox
play the mariners at some bar.
And my buddy,
he came in for the first three innings
and then he left and I was like,
you know what,
I'm going to hang out.
And I just sorta just stayed there and
had like five Heineken's in the middle of
the day.
Now I know all you youngsters out there
like five Heineken's in the middle of
the day. What do you fucking Pussy, what
do I say it? It's, it's all you got.
I don't know what the ages, but there
becomes an age. Jesus Christ look at,
I got like a fucking double Chin
looking at myself in the mirror.
That's when you know you've been boozing.
If you got to like a fucking two days
scruff and all of a sudden you got like
that Pelican Chin, uh, on
a fucking mess. I like,
you know, I don't know. I gotta get
Outta here. That's the fucking point.
So anyways,
so I have like five beers and uh,
it was that perfect.
No,
five beers is like that point
where you don't think you're drunk.
So you continue talking to people and uh,
I dunno,
it just sucks.
Stricken in the middle of day sucks
because you go through the whole fucking
hangover, you know, usually when you just
pass out at the end of the night, I mean,
you sleep through most of your fucking
hangover as opposed to this one where I
came off and I just sort of gradually
came down and I would not off like a
fucking old man and then wake up back
again and just wake up back again.
It doesn't even make any sense.
I'd wake up again. I don't know.
I'm all over the fucking place. I
want to get out of here. I've had it,
fucking had it. I've had it. So anyways,
I went up to see some family over the
4th of July to celebrate the birthday of
this country. And, um,
as I'm driving up,
I'm listening on the radio and
evidently I looked up the song on,
uh,
on the Internet.
It's a Carrie Underwood song, who
I don't, I don't know what she is.
I'm guessing she's white cause it sounded
country and she had a little Twang in
her voice, but I don't want to
piss off any Koreans out there.
She might've been Korean.
Um,
is a song called before he cheat.
So I'm driving along and you know,
I'm driving my buddy's car.
This is how I'm going to
fucking defend myself.
That I was on a radio station that was
actually playing this and I was just sort
of clicking the, uh, the
preprogram radios. Fucking yeah,
whatever. You know what I'm saying?
I'm hung, I'm feel like shit.
Cut me some slack this week. So
anyways, this song comes on and this,
this Carrie Underwood chick is sitting
there singing this song going rat.
Now he's probably slow dancing.
Bam Pratt now and she's
singing about her boyfriend.
I got the lyrics right here.
Right now.
He's probably buying her some fruity
little drink cause she can't shoot whiskey
right now. He's probably up
behind her with the pool stick,
showing her how to shoot a
combo. I, then they go into the,
the chorus and she goes and he don't know,
um,
that I dug my keys into the side of
his pretty little souped up four wheel
drive,
carve my name and to his leather seats.
I took a Louisville
slugger to both headlights,
slashed a hole in all four tires.
And all I could think was,
why don't you just break up with them?
You dumb cunt.
You know what I mean?
What are you going to do?
You're going to do all this shit.
Then he's going to get mad and then what
you're going to make up after five days
and then you're going to blow them again.
I hate this fucking song and I'm going
to tell you why, because it's, I,
I'm pretty sure it's a hit.
It's on the radio, right? Uh,
I dunno.
And what do I love about this is people
will listen to this song and they won't
even question the rationale of what
the fuck someone's doing in there.
Because so many people in life,
myself included,
you, you, you play, you like powerless in
life. You just play the powerless card.
You know,
just get out of the fucking relationship.
I fucking hate this song and
this is one of these songs too.
We're fucking women all get together.
They started saying,
hey gang ass car,
you're all a bunch of dumb cunts.
Okay, you're fucking stupid.
Just break up with the guy.
Just break up with them.
Not even to mention the fact that now
you're going out there and you're,
you're doing damage. You're, I don't know,
is that a fellow that's not a felony?
I don't know what it is,
but it's just a classic thing where a
woman would listen to that song and at no
point would she ever think, man,
maybe I could get arrested for this.
I am damaging somebody's property.
No, you gotta fucking Vagina.
You can just go out in broad daylight.
You don't even have to
wear a fucking mask.
Do you know what I would have to do
if I wanted to go out and go fuck up
somebody's car? I would have
to wait for the, first of all,
I'd have to make sure I had an alibi.
It'd be like I was killing somebody.
I had to make sure somebody could
cover for me and say that I was fucking
somewhere,
right.
I had to put on some goddamn cat
suit and a fucking a mask. Right?
Like I'm in that dead presidents
movie and all I would able to get,
I'd be able to get off one quick
hit, right? One quick hit. Let's,
I want to start carving it up
like a pussy. Right? But if I,
if I really was going to go out there
and smash somebody who's headlights,
I can hit one and the second
the car alarm goes off,
I have to fucking take
off and then run home,
get out of my little fucking fucking a
little cat suit and then try to put on my
pajamas.
So when the cops show up,
because you know they're going to
find some sort of fucking fingerprint,
I gotta Act like I'm not out of breath.
Like I actually have been sitting there
for fucking eight hours watching TV.
I Dunno. I just, I can't stand, you know,
it just reminds me of when that movie,
a fatal attraction came out,
right.
And the amount of women who would just
sit there and you see that movie? Huh?
Yeah. That's what you get
three you get, you know,
there's no thought of like
this bitch put a rabbit in, in,
in boiling water.
There's none of that women there.
They're out of their fucking minds.
But that's not even the point of this.
My point of the Carrie Underwood song,
it actually made me feel like a loser
because the amount of fucking times,
I mean I going out and
fucked up somebody's car,
but the amount of times you don't,
what does that song is? That song?
It's a powerless song.
That's what the fuck it is.
And I went to the whole lyrics to see if
she breaks up with them in the end and
there's sort of an ambiguous line
in the end where she goes, uh,
cause the next time he cheats,
oh, you know, it won't be on me.
So that sort of ambiguous because it
could mean because I broke up with them or
it could be because he doesn't
want to get his truck fucked up.
So I don't know. You know, I, I just
at just fucking annoys me.
That song just annoyed the shit out of me
on both levels where you got somebody,
it's like,
just break up with a guy
and your solution is,
you know, something. If a girl
ever fucking cheated on me that,
that I would break up with them.
I'm not saying I wouldn't flip out
and I give him a good fucking trashing
verbally, but I would
never go in like, uh, what,
you know, throw all their clothes
out in the front line and Burnham,
you know, why wouldn't I do
that? I had, I don't know why.
I think a lot of it has to do because
I'd be fucking worried I'd get arrested
for damaging property.
Why don't women have an exemption from
damaging property? I don't understand it.
Of a woman sat there
smashing up somebody's car
in broad daylight because the
guy cheated on him. People would
be laughing. I would be laughing.
Everyone. It's, it's a
comedy. It's just hilarious.
But if the exact same scenario
was going down in a guy did it,
he used to be the classic,
you know the cops come and
they put you in that little,
you get tasered and they mush your face
into the fucking pavement. I Dunno,
I get it.
Women have to carry a kid around and
that goddamn stomach for nine months,
but I don't think that gives you the
right to go out and tack somebody Sphero I
really don't. You know, so why don't
you guys just fucking relax. All right.
You're a bunch of Goddamn
Psychos, you know, with your,
I'm on my period excuse. So three weeks
a month, you're out of your fucking mind.
I think if a girl goes, even if you were
cheating on a girl or on a woman, right?
And she fucks up your car,
I really think you ought to be able to
go up to her and give her a nice fucking
two piece combination to
the Goddamn fucking cabbage.
What do you think about
that? Right? Just fucking,
just hook off on that fucking
hair teased. Head of lettuce on the
top of her fucking shoulders. Right?
What would you go with?
I'm really going to alienate
a lot of my pants on this one.
And I want you to know that most of this
is not me advocating punching a woman
in the face.
Most of this is,
I can't fucking sit in this
stupid hotel room anymore.
I can't fucking do it.
I've had the Goddamn
do not disturb light
on for like four days.
They probably think I overdosed in here.
I'm really big on that.
Don't clean up the
room. Beat it. You know,
you got to come in and every three days
and changes the sheets like I'm royalty.
I changed the sheets like
fucking once every three weeks.
Maybe that's, that's only if they have
white and I can tell how filthy they are.
That's right. Wrinkle your nose
up. You fucking pompous broads.
That's how I live my life. Um,
Jesus. Why am I attacking women?
I don't know why. What did I
talk about? Oh yeah. If you,
if you could punch a woman in a face,
you allow two punches,
what would you go with?
Okay. What'd you go? Classic.
Would you set up the overhand right with
the jab? Would you actually waste a jet?
You know, waste a jab which you go,
this is just evil. All right, I gotta get
off this fucking subject. I don't know,
that song just annoyed me.
Um,
I hate those fucking songs when women
just just openly talk about how they're
going to go out and destroy a guy's
fucking property rather than break up with
them, you know, and it's considered
some sort of justification, you know,
rather than looking inward going, you
know, maybe I'm a bad judge of character.
What sort of qualities are
am I looking for in somebody?
And I'll date that.
I mean,
didn't the fact that the guy had a
souped up four wheel drive truck,
didn't that give it all up within that?
Give it away on any fucking level,
Huh? I mean a souped up four wheel
drive truck. Carrie Underwood,
you dumb fucking, what
else did he have? Huh? Uh,
a fucking earring hanging down with
a lightening bolt on the side of it.
It had this fucking song sticks.
This is one of the,
you know why I hate to sign this and
I'm going to do my whole podcast on this
fucking song.
This is going to be one of those fucking
songs when I'm on the road and I'm
hating my life,
you know,
and I just don't want to go back to the
hotel room and be lonely and I'm going
to go out to a bar and that song's gonna
come on and fucking four fucking twats
with their ear piercing.
I'm singing and I'm drunk.
High pitch voices are going to start
singing every fucking word of that song.
Liked it.
They like these fucking cunt bad asses.
Okay. And I'm done. All right. I'm done
with that. I'm done with that fucking Ah,
Jesus Christ.
That fucking song annoyed me.
What a fucking loser that
Carrie Underwood is. Huh?
Is that an anthem for all you
broads out there? You know,
I love about this is I'm really like,
I'm really taking the,
literally the dumbest
demographic of women and a,
and I'm just fucking super imposing
it over all women and I'm doing it on
purpose because this,
cause I'm childish this week
I'm fucking in a bad mood.
And um,
you know,
rather than doing some yoga and going
out and getting a Veggie Omelet or
whatever dumb shit you're supposed to do,
what you look at my fucking face,
this bloated booze face.
Oh Jesus Christ. What happened? I
wasn't, you know, my life was great.
I came to New York on, okay,
this is awesome. You know,
live in a dream here and I'm gonna, I'm
gonna eat right. I'm not gonna drink.
I'm going to work out every day.
And you know,
I don't know what happened. Oh, I
know. What happened was the, this,
the second day I got here was my birthday.
So you got a drink on your birthday
and then I just got the booze coursing
through my veins and then it's just,
it's just been a, it's just been a,
I can't even say drunken debauchery.
It's just been sort of sad old man.
I've kind of been sitting there like norm
in cheers. If he didn't know anybody,
you know,
cliff Klavan didn't come in and butcher
his name with his bad Boston accent a
then Nami nom. It's norm.
Just take the r out.
If you want to do a Boston accent, that's
what you do. You just take the r out.
Everything doesn't become an ae. I know
I've mentioned that before, but uh,
you know how the deal is people
in North Dakota. I went there,
Fargo when I brought up that movie
and they were just like, dude,
we don't fucking talk like that.
That movie was annoying,
but everyone else thought it was hilarious
because how many of us have ever been
to Fargo, North Dakota and the
same thing with chairs, you know,
everybody thinks, oh, that's, that's
how they say norm. They say Nami.
Now they don't, they
say, no, I'm all right.
Does this make any fucking sense?
This is just like, I am like a,
I'm just cutting to the week right now.
Um,
what else did I want to talk about
that I do? Anything this week,
I don't think I did anything.
I started to read a book,
just reading a book on the mob.
Why don't I just start reading
some shit cause I'm actually,
this is my last day of
shooting and I'm excited.
I'm really excited about
this scene because I have
the most lines of any scene,
you know, and uh, and he seen
that I, that I've been in,
which means I have 1.5 not kidding,
actually get like two or three lines,
which is going to be cool. And I'm
really excited to do this shit, but, uh,
I got to get this fucking
podcast out of the way.
Can you tell I'm scrolling
down. Um, all right, here's one.
I got this dude in England who
always fucking emails me and uh,
I guess he was sick of me not re
reading his questions or whatever.
So in the title, whatever you call it,
the subject line, he said, read this,
you fucking cunt. So of course I
have to open it. And he said, sorry,
you're not a content. I just need to
get your attention. All right. Hey,
bill dynamite podcast. This week
or should I say last week? Well,
because it's Wednesday and, oh,
look, no Monday morning podcasts,
because I was really looking forward to
hearing you talk about your dog for 40
minutes again, dude, we get it.
You have a dog. No one cares.
Be funnier.
That's my main point.
Also renamed the podcast bill birth
speaks for 40 minutes because for a start,
it's hardly ever out on a Monday.
And also you do ramble aimlessly.
Uh, it's called a podcast. You fucking
moron. What do you think a podcast is?
Are there a bunch of podcasts out there
where people aren't babbling aimlessly?
Podcasts are basically fucking radio shows
for people who weren't good enough to
be on the fucking radio.
So I don't know what's what level
of quality you're looking for here,
but you're really need to lower
your standards. All right,
and who the fuck says dynamite?
Are they still saying that over there?
Did you guys just get good times?
Okay.
All right. Here we go. Let's
continue here. Um, anyways, uh,
I'm not trying to trash you because
sometimes it's great. Oh, that's cool.
I'm glad.
Sometimes it's great.
I just think bill birth speaks
for 40 minutes is a better title.
Take a lead my advice, but my main point,
stop talking about the dog. It kills me.
I fast forward when,
when, uh, when you do,
nobody cares about your fucking dog.
But apart from that,
the show is great and I love your
work. One quick question. Um,
I can see how it'd be annoying
if I was talking to my dog.
I know there's a bunch of animal lovers
right now. Listen to this going. No,
I really enjoy it. Um, fuck you
dude. I love my dog. All right.
Why don't you go get some fish and chips
and not brush your teeth or whatever
other hacky fucking thing
you guys do over there. Huh?
Geeta pork chop for breakfast.
Yeah, man. I'm trying to think.
The last good looking person
that came from England,
pay towns in with that warp knows.
Was there anybody good
looking even what's his face?
Roger Daltrey who wasn't shape, but
his face is just, it's just beat.
Just beat down, man. You just weathered,
weathered, fucking people over there.
Um, I can't, I don't think I've ever
remembered that anybody ever say,
and they met some hot chicken England.
I've heard it. You know, you go to France,
you go to Sweden,
you know you go to Spain,
right? You go to Puerto Rico, there's
all kinds of fucking hot women.
You go to England, Dude,
look at the royal family.
Actually,
Princess Diana was kind of hot,
but she had weird fucking hands and feet.
She looked like she was part lizard.
She was, did she look like a
beautiful lizard? That's what she,
that's what she looked like. And
Prince Charles looks like, um, uh,
you know what?
I don't have the fucking
medical background to talk
about how inbred that guy is.
You know what I mean? But he
just basically, I don't know.
I don't know what he has.
He has one of whatever the fuck he has
and it's all the same coursing through
his fucking body, whatever.
If I fell a regular mug,
human being has to shut up hill.
You're too fucking stupid to go through
with this. All right, one quick question,
Bill. How long did it take to
crack? The standup scene. I mean,
when you started getting
decent money and radio spots.
Uh,
let's see.
Well took me three and a half
years before I quit my day job,
but I was living at home and I saved
every dime that I made from work that I
could. And I also saved every
dime that I was making from um,
stand up and I basically
saved up 10 grand,
uh,
which believe it or not,
you can do if you don't run out
and buy every new fucking I iPhone,
iPod and all laptops and all that shit.
I didn't do any of that.
I just dressed like Malcolm young
and ACDC jeans and tee shirt.
I had a fucking,
I had this old pickup truck that
I used to drive two wheel drive,
one of the little little ones.
And I drove that until it fucking died.
And I was at this critical point where
I was only a year into my standup career
and I needed a reliable car,
but I also didn't want to
be chained to my job by,
by buying a new car, which is the
dumbest fucking thing you can do.
If you're in your 20s and you got
some job and it's not your business,
it's not your own business and you know
you want to leave it at some point,
that dumbest fucking thing you can
do is go out and buy a brand new car.
You just change yourself to your desk.
I know I've said this before,
but it's like that.
You don't remember,
you remember in a Bronx tale when those
bikers are acting like assholes and they
ask them to leave and they don't
leave and then they fucking, you know,
put the thing on the door and then Chazz
Palminteri goes, now you can't leave.
You're,
you're,
you're doing the financial equivalent
of that scene when you go out and buy a
brand new fucking car. Okay, first of all,
you can afford a good car.
You just going to get some generic fucking
twenty thousand twenty five thousand
dollars stupid ass fucking car.
And it's, it's, it's gonna,
it's gonna change the death.
So long story short,
what I did was instead of
buying a new car was I, I just,
I had a new engine put in my
putting my truck and everybody,
all the fucking people at work told me
that said, dumbest thing, do what do you,
what do you or do for you?
Fuck them.
A really cost me 50 [inaudible] at the
time because it costs about 1500 bucks to
get the whole thing done.
Right.
As opposed to have a $15,000 car loan.
I had the fucking engine paid off, you
know, on about four or five months.
Then I had no car payment
again and I could,
I could use that to put
towards my nest egg. And My,
my idea when I went down to New York
was I was going to get a day job,
but uh, you know, a w you know,
I waited a couple of weeks
before I started looking
and I started doing standup
and then I got a couple of gigs and they
were on the road so I couldn't get a
day job. And believe me, my
10 grand was fucking going
down, down, down, down, down.
But it bought me enough
fucking time where I could, uh,
I could get in with the clubs,
start getting gigs. And,
um,
what ended up happening,
I think I went all the way down
to like fucking 2,500 bucks.
And uh,
I think that's when,
then I started booking shit.
That's what happened.
Then I started booking shit
and I was able to sustain,
um,
it didn't dip below 2,500,
but it didn't really get
above three grand either.
I got to that point where I could,
I could basically pay my bills and uh,
that's also back when somebody
told me about, you know,
paying off your fucking credit cards,
um,
every month so you don't get fucked
with the, uh, on the interest.
I started doing that and I basically,
I ate spaghetti like every fucking night.
Pasta is a really cheap meal.
It fills you up. I told you about this
shit before and when I went on the road,
I would go to Denny's or the international
house of pancakes and I get the large
stack of pancakes in the morning.
I get the five stack and they would sit
in my stomach like fucking cement and I
could literally go from like eight in
the morning to eight at night without
eating.
And you know,
I drive my little rented fucking dodge
neon to some college gig. There you go.
When you get a college Gig, that's a big
thing. So about three and a half years.
All right, I'm sorry dude.
Was that fucking boring?
I know I didn't talk about my dog
and do an am just breaking your balls
sometimes like people give me shit and I
give him shit back and people think I'm
serious. I really don't give a fuck.
Um, all right, now here's is overrated,
underrated list. Overrated
bill burrs dog. No one cares.
Bruce Springsteen, bloated overrated
stadium rocker. Barack Obama.
He can't,
he can't hide behind the black forever.
The economy is still fucked.
Ah, Jesus Christ. Dude, did
you even proof read this?
He can't hide behind the black forever.
The economy is still fucked. Um,
dude, I dunno if you fucking
notice, but we had a, uh,
we've had a war for a good fucking seven
years to the tune of $1 billion a month
and bankers loaned out money to homeless
people and we had to bail them out.
So I think I don't give a shit who the
fuck you are. Republican, Democrat,
liberal, conservative.
Fucking independent.
You're not getting us out of this,
which is why I am going to Sweden.
I have a gig coming up in
Sweden and the end of August,
I'm going to start doing a
Australia once a year. Um,
this talks about me going to Dublin.
These fucking overseas gigs,
they're very hard to get. You know,
shit usually ends up falling out,
but that's my thing. All right. If
these corporations are going global,
going global too. I want to give a fuck.
I'll be the Goddamn James Bond. A comedy.
James Bond, I dunno.
International Man of jokes. Um,
underrated arctic monkeys.
It's a great British band from
Sheffield, England, cocaine,
brilliant song by Eric Clapton. Dude, you
must be young. Okay? That song's great.
The first 40,000 times
you hear it, but id, Eh,
um, underrated football slash soccer,
easily the best sport ever. Hands down.
Um, you know what? I wouldn't argue that.
I wouldn't argue that because
if you actually, if you,
if you watch American soccer,
it's sucks like an American
team versus an American team.
But if you watch that oversee shit,
you know where people fucking die and
people get trampled in crushed to death
and then they go on youtube and talk about
how dumb Americans are. Um, you know,
you'd think what those
awful English teeth,
you can eat your way through the fence
when you're getting crushed up against,
uh, the people in England even have
bad teeth or is my entire fucking, uh,
understanding of England, basically
three Austin power movies. All right?
Probably is. All right, let's talk
about grenades again this week.
Um, I asked somebody,
when you throw a grenade,
how long do you have before the fucking
thing goes off? And it said, Bill,
three to four seconds sounds about
right. Uh, I'm still amazed at that.
Crazy son of a bitch who was filming,
didn't use a tripod or some shit. Oh yeah.
If you guys want to see what a
fucking grenade does, go on youtube.
Look up grenade in washing machine.
I believe that's what you search. Uh,
some Army Guy, cause I
asked last week, you know,
whenever you see a those army movies,
somebody dives on a fucking
grenade and uh, you know,
saves the life of his
comrades. Um, I dunno,
this conflicting advice that I got
on this shit. You know what dude,
I'm fucking losing it right now.
This podcast is,
is quickly spinning out of control
because I haven't eaten yet. And uh,
I have an early pickup today
and if I don't do it now,
it's not going to be coming out on Monday.
So I why I'm just gonna
Start Reading Shit here. Um,
all right. If you want to talk
about weaponry, what's the,
what is the question I asked last
week? Oh, I asked, I asked, uh,
if there's any people in the military,
if they had any combat stories,
because I was talking about,
you know,
whenever you fantasize about going to war,
you always picture yourself doing some
Rambo Shit. But in the back of your head,
you know that there's a strong possibility
that you might be that fucking dude
who when the shit goes down,
you can't move.
You freeze or you fucking balled
up in the fetal position crying.
You know, I heard a story one time is
sometimes in battle people just stand up.
They can't deal with it anymore and
they just kill themselves. Granted,
I heard that from my high school teacher
who's teaching the English and uh,
he had never been to war, you
know, so that's probably bullshit.
Um, anyway, so here's a guy that
actually went to combat. He said, Bill,
you asking your podcasts about the
first time you're outside the wire,
which is military jargon for leaving
protected base in Iraq or Afghanistan.
And this dude said, I was absolutely
terrified for the first couple of weeks.
But the trick is that you can't let
anybody around you know that you're scared
because you don't want, you don't
want to look like a pussy. Uh,
the rules of engagement are strict.
We were ordered to not
shoot back unless we could.
We could see who was shooting at us.
Is that true?
You couldn't shoot back unless you saw
who was shooting back at you? Dude, uh,
I would break that rule if I wasn't on
the ground crying in the fetal position.
Oh my God, this young man
is, I don't want to do this.
If I could actually get past that,
I would be definitely shooting in the
general fucking direction of wherever it
was through fuck that.
Fuck that.
This war is different from other wars and
so far as we are fighting right in the
middle of where normal people lived and
we tried hard not to kill any of them.
Um, you know what, I'm not a
student of military history,
but I think most wars are kind
of where people are at. Um,
I think back in the revolutionary days
that you would go out and stand in a line
out in the field or even in the civil war.
But, uh, I know they had
the front in World War One,
but at some point when you're kicking
the other teams as you end up in their
backyard, cause a lot of them
don't just give up like, well you,
you beat us on our field.
We wouldn't want to go into this town
and hide amongst the civilians. You know,
am I wrong there on PR? I don't
know if I'm wrong. How do,
how does Dresden happen if, if, if
you know,
I don't know.
Okay.
Well I don't fucking know,
Dude. I'm out of it. Let's,
let's just get to the fucking
questions for the week and uh,
well I can, I can gradually fucking
bail out of this thing. Um, oh, okay.
Overrated. Underrated Bill. People
Bitch about the, uh, gas prices are a,
I guess over a to bill people bitch
about the greedy oil companies whenever
there are high gas prices and also about
how there are no alternative energy
options for transportation.
What they don't seem to understand
is that no sane entrepreneur,
entrepreneur is going to invest in diamond
developing alternative energy until
gas gets to $10 a gallon and people are
converting their vacuum cleaners into
segues to get to work. We can
either have one or the other. Um,
dude, um, it's not quite as
simplistic as that. Yeah,
there definitely has to be some sort
of outrage from the people. But uh,
okay.
You know what,
rather than get into fucking details,
look up a guy stand mayor m e y e r at
this guy actually came up with a car that
ran on water, rain water,
fresh water, salt water.
It didn't make a fucking difference and
he basically figured out a way where you
could get across the country,
14 and a half gallons and the
dumb fuck told people about it,
went to the news, they
announced it on, uh,
we played it on the opiod Anthony show.
They talked about it on the news and then
they said that there was somebody from
the Pentagon who is so excited.
They sent a lieutenant colonel
out there to check out his device.
Basically what happens is when you come
up with some shit like that is they go
out there and they, they sort of tell
you that it's very wise for you to buy,
to sell them the patent of it, you
know? And then if you don't play ball,
you mysteriously die four or five years
later and your invention disappears.
Stand mayor, look it up. That's what
the fuck happens. All right dude. Um,
I've always used the iPod.
I used to do a bit about this shit.
You're telling me basically that I can
have my entire fucking record collection,
you know,
8,000 fucking songs in my pocket,
but they can't come up with the car that
can't do better with the gas mileage.
Dude. It's all bullshit. Would you
basically have at the top is you have ra,
the robber baron,
blue blood blood families and uh,
some of the underworld guys who went
legitimate and the government is middle
management for these mother fuckers and
the guys at the top, they run everything.
Banks are at the top and
then the blue blood guys,
I think the corporations are the next
level. And then it's the politicians.
Okay. And this is coming from a
completely uninformed jackass. Fuck that.
I've read a couple of books,
but I think that that's what's going on.
That's what's going on.
And you know,
I don't know how you can invent shit
nowadays and actually get it up to the
public.
You have to basically be working for a
corporation that has the money to put it
out there. So then basically they
own it. You know what I mean?
I guess you could kind of try and be the
Tyler Perry of fucking inventing shit.
Um, you know, what, can I just
tap out of this fucking podcast?
I don't even know what the hell I'm
talking about. I'm fucking on the road.
I'm lonely. I want to see my fucking
dog. I want to get back to my girl.
I'm going to get back to my fucking life
and I want to do a good job today on
set. So I don't fuck this thing up because
I've had a great God damn time. And,
um,
I fly back
in a couple of days and a
couple of fucking days and
I'm really looking forward
to it. Oh, did I tell you guys I a,
I bought the hangover when
I was drunk in the bar.
I bought the hangover of
some fucking, uh, I dunno,
50 year old Asian woman came
walking in, you know, it was great.
It was like fucking
portable,
a blockbuster video and I bought
the hangover for five bucks.
Great bootleg copy only a couple of times.
Did somebody stand up and walk by?
Do you guy?
You know,
that's the great thing about living in
New York as is all the bootleg movies
that she can fucking buy.
And it basically someone just goes into
the movie theater with a video camera
and they just film the screen and it's
great cause you can hear other people
laughing.
It's kind of like mystery science theater.
And then somebody kind of adjusts their,
their seat in front and all of a sudden
you see somebody's head and you're
trying to look around it,
you know,
or somebody just gets up in the middle
and starts walking down the row and it's,
it's funny to me, but, uh, I actually,
I saw it, man. I was all right.
It was, it was fucking all right. I
guess five bucks. Can you compliant?
Can you complain?
I wish I met this lady at the beginning
of my fucking a trip out here.
I would've had, I would've
bought like 58 of them. Yeah.
So next time you're in New York,
all right.
In the cute little Asian lady comes
walking and going, am I really doing this?
Am I advocating the stealing of
shit? I think it's over. Anyways.
People send me emails. Hey, I listened
to all your running forums. Uh,
I downloaded them for free.
Sorry.
They always got to tell you that they got
your shit for free. And then they say,
sorry.
You know what I mean?
I pay for my music's, you fucking cunts
pay for my comedy. All right. Whatever.
That's the end of this podcast.
Um,
literally dizzy right now. Uh,
the fuck am hyping. All right,
next week I go back to my
life as a standup comedian.
I'm going to be at the punchline
in San Francisco, uh, on Monday,
July the 13th,
and I'm doing two shows and it's going
to be just like the last time where I'm
going to try to do as little material
from my act as humanly possible and I'm
just going to tell you some fucked
up stories, uh, from my childhood,
from my dating life to
uh, to whatever, you know.
Um, and then the following week I'm going
to be at the comedy works in Denver,
Colorado. Um, that's
the 23rd, 24th and 25th.
And then I believe I'm gearing
up to do another special,
so I'm going to be on the road
pretty much right through August,
September, October, November and December.
I am pretty much going to be doing three
out of four weeks on the road and um,
I'm going to be getting this fucking
special together and hopefully I will be
shooting it in San Francisco.
That is,
that is the goal to shoot
it in San Francisco and uh,
to have a very funny, memorable, special,
that's what the fuck I want to do.
And the stress of it is already
starting to hit me because, uh,
I dunno, you know, you don't want it
to suck. You don't want it to suck.
The reality is, is I wish I had another
fucking six months just because I'm lazy,
but I know if it on bullshit. All right.
I'm just, I'm just really, I'm babbling.
I need nourishment.
I need to stop drinking and I need to
go downstairs under the treadmill and
somehow get some of this fucking booze
weight out of my Goddamn Chin. All right,
that it, that's the Monday
morning podcast. Um, I,
if I had to critique this podcast,
I would say would,
it was like when evil Knievel tried to
jump the snake river in that rocket,
you know, where it started off fast and
you thought I was going to fuck them.
That's what the I did.
Do you know what happened to this podcast?
The fucking parachute came
out halfway through it,
and then I just slowly went down towards
the snake river and actually have a
bloody nose right now, just
like evil Knievel. All right,
I'm going to go get some eggs. Uh,
God bless you. Hope to see you in a,
if you live anywhere near San Francisco,
hope to see audit my gig and uh,
please keep the questions
coming next week.
I'm going to give you a
great podcast because a, um,
I'll be back in my home life and I'll
be eating right and I won't be drinking
and a brace yourself.
Douche bag from England.
I'm probably going to be talking about
how excited I am to see my fucking dog.
All right. That's it. Everybody a good
[inaudible]. [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].